No, thank you very much for your help. Really
gentle Jesus. 25 minutes left for
that. Hurry up from here.  It
's
okay, I'll take you to your room Is it
really okay?  I do
n't have many memories because I lost my wife, but what about
married life
?  It's different from parents and siblings
What's special about friends and lovers will soon be
revealed Husband [music] Hey, what are you doing in a place like this,
Tsukasa-chan?
It's Chitose's grandmother, who was in the witness column of the report.  I
'm a bad person, or
rather, I'm a bad
person.  I was
just trying to push myself to the limits of I'm
saying I'm deceiving you Even as I grow older, I
won't forget the challenge spirit
I'm not going to
introduce you to my husband.  do
n't laugh